[Musique]
la toune 2 est enfin sortie et ce jeu
refait totalement été développé par
nintendo ce plateau est un jeu de tir à
la troisième personne où nous incarnons
des inkling des sorte d'enfant calamars
habitants à chroma police le jeu se base
sur le principe de peinture où nous
devons recouvrir le terrain pour gagner
la partie tuer nos ennemis ou bien
rechargées enfin bref je vais pas vous
apprendre ce plateau aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de ce qu la toune de
sortir récemment car j'ai trouvé une
petite théorie vraiment sympa sur le net
et que j'avais envie de vous partager et
vous développez à ma façon
si vous avez joué à ce que tous une
premier du nom sur wiiu vous devez
forcément connaître qui piquent un pnj
du jeu qui exercent un commerce autour
des vêtements et des coquillages et bien
à la théorie tournerait autour de ce
personnage danse platoon 2 vous avez la
présence d'un nouveau mode appelé
salmonsson le but est simple vous êtes
engagé par monsieur ours une sorte de
robot statue en forme d'ours
vous êtes une équipe de quatre joueurs
qui devront éliminer des salles mono ide
et des salles monobrosse afin de
récupérer des oeufs de poissons dorée
durant trois vagues d'assaut la
difficulté varie en fonction du niveau
attribué au joueur mais maintenant
passons au vif du sujet et cie qui pique
était en fête
mais monsieur course tout d'abord il
faut savoir que qui piquait tam nomme de
business comme il est marqué sur un
parchemin du mode solo de ce platoon de
il est dit qu'un article expliquant
comment devenir riche rapidement rédigé
par un jeune homme à la coupole
je me suis fait 10 millions en un an
simplement en posant mon popotin dans la
rue fait devant autant qui croiraient
paris sornettes
nous savons que qui piquent a maintenant
changé business ans platoon 2 nous le
voyons d'ailleurs dans chrome os police
il est dans une maison probablement la
sienne et reste devant un ordinateur
le parchemin nous indique bien qu'il ait
passé de la rue a maintenant riche dans
une maison ce serait pourquoi il a
changé de business car c'est maintenant
tipi qui se charge du commerce de
coquillages et de vêtements et
s'intéresserait maintenant aux yeux
dorés un commerce encore plus bénéfique
et engagerait quotidiennement des
inkling pour l'aider il en a les moyens
après tout monsieur ours serait une
couverture c'est un nom de code
nous voyons simplement une sorte de
robot statuette d'ours nous parlait avec
une voix robotique en plus qui piquent
contrôlerait cette machine depuis sa
maison via son ordinateur
et nous donnerait des instructions qui
fit qu'est devenu quelqu'un d'assez
puissant danse platoon 2 et pourrait se
permettre de faire travailler des
inkling pour accroître son business
enfin il reste deux arguments qui font
pencher la balance envers cette théorie
monsieur ours et qui piquent sont les
deux seuls personnages de l'univers ce
platoon à nous appeler petite tête
aucun autre nous appelle ainsi c'est une
marque de langage propre à qui piquent à
la base donc une raison de plus de
croire qu'il serait monsieur ours et
puis après avoir réfléchi de mon côté
sur cette théorie quelque chose m'est
venu à l'esprit qui piquent est un
oursin à la base et serait donc monsieur
ours
son nom de code est pour justement
cacher son identité ours serait le
diminutif de oursins qui symbolise
typique c'est un petit peu tiré par les
cheveux mais ça a tilté dans ma tête
c'est une petite théorie mais qui
fonctionne et c'est un mystère qui me
plaît énormément
je remercie sonics play de m'avoir aidé
à peaufiner la théorie n'hésitez pas à
me dire ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires et je remercie ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur twitter pour les plus
acharnés d'entre vous cet argot rock et
que le liner soit avec vous prague
brit-brit